das hier
sind Feldpostbriefe von meinem Opa
geschrieben an meine Oma 1941 von der
Ostfront da war er Pionier und als
wehrmachtsoldat im Einsatz ich lese euch
mal aus einem vor der Übergang über den
neaper ist erzwungen und in kurzer Zeit
rollt der Firma weiter gleich sind es 9
Wochen wann kommt die letzte doch kommen
muss und wird sie und mit ihr der Sieg
dessen sind wir alle felsenfest
überzeugt dann aber gibt's wieder Urlaub
ein Wiedersehen mit dir aus den neuen
Wochen wurden hunderte Wochen der
deutsche Vernichtungskrieg endete dann
aber erst nach knapp vier Jahren mit der
Niederlage es wird schnell gehen
ähnliches mögen russische Soldaten im
Frühling gedacht und auch vielleicht
geschrieben haben als sie ihn
umgekehrter Richtung überquerten ohne
Hitlers und Putins Angriffskriege
irgendwie gleichsetzen zu wollen es
zeigt zumindest Erwartung an das Ende
eines begonnenen Krieges liegen oft
komplett daneben natürlich wollen wir
alle dass dieser ich sag's mal so scheiß
Krieg endlich
das ist unsere
unserer Sichtweise auf diesen Konflikt
nur als militärsdrücker der jetzt
vielleicht die die längeren Linien
verfolgt muss ich sagen die meisten
Kriege zwischenstaatlichen Kriege dauern
eben länger oft ist es so dass Kriege
eben ganz anders enden als diejenigen
dachten die den Krieg begonnen haben
wann hört dieser Krieg auf stehen wir am
Anfang oder am Ende wie könnte Frieden
Aussehen ist jetzt die Zeit für
Verhandlungen die Ukraine hat aus meiner
Sicht überhaupt keine Alternative als so
schnell wie möglich zu Verhandlungen zu
kommen wenn diese Exponenten nun sagen
ein Krieg müsste durch Verhandlungen
enden dann möchte ich diese Leute ganz
konkret Fragen hätten sie 1944 mit Adolf
Hitler verhandelt okay das ist ein
harter Vergleich putin ist sicher nicht
Hitler und der Angriff auf die Ukraine
ein regionaler kein totaler Krieg aber
worum es geht im Kern ist kann man mit
einem Kriegstreiber überhaupt verhandeln
und wenn ja wann ist die richtige
Zeitpunkt liegt die Kriegsentscheidung
in der Luft all das in dieser Folge
willkommen zu inside-politics
[Applaus]
eine Ausgabe die es eigentlich gar nicht
geben dürfte laut
Expertenmeinung im Februar müsste der
Krieg eigentlich längst vorbei sein ich
denke putin wird diesen Krieg gewinnen
weil die russischen Streitkräfte modern
sind gut ausgestattet sind Militärhilfe
jetzt noch zu leisten bringt nichts mehr
aktuell für den laufenden Konflikt das
alles reicht nicht also militärisch
gesehen ist die Sache gelaufen und meine
Bewertung ist dass es nur ein paar um
ein paar Tage gehen wird und nicht mehr
es kam bekanntlich ganz anders russland
hat sehr wenig erreicht das Ziel die
Ukraine zu überrennen Einnahme der
Hauptstadt regime change in Kiew alles
kläglich gefloppt nach wenigen Wochen
das Ziel den Don Bass komplett unter
Kontrolle zu bekommen und einzuverleiben
bis heute nicht in Sicht gleichzeitig
vergiftet sich die Rhetorik immer mehr
sie Lenski reagierte auf bekannt
gewordene verbal Provokation von Putin
indem er davon sprach ihm persönlich
gerne die Fresse polieren zu wollen und
aus Russland auch dort unversöhnliche
martialische Töne und Drohung so fordert
ein Parlamentsabgeordneter aus
putinspartei Einiges Russland dem
russischen Fernsehen
Verhandlungen ja aber erst wenn die
russische Armee die Grenzen der Ukraine
erreicht hat die Grenzen zu Polen des
Slowakei Ungarn und Rumänien totale
Besatzung oder nichts oder der ehemalige
Botschafter Russlands bei der NATO der
offen droht das wird erst enden wenn wir
Kiew eingenommen haben dazu offene
vernichtungsphantasien die Ukraine müsse
von der Landkarte gelöscht werden also
hört man die ganze Bandbreite von
martialischen Tönen das ist auch so
gewollt das ist auch dieser Spin der
hier gezeigt wird und die ganze
Bandbreite was alles möglich ist Drogen
mit Kalkül also sagt unser ZDF
Korrespondent in Moskau mit dem ich für
diese Ausgabe auch gesprochen habe kann
sich das manchmal gar nicht vorstellen
dass das wirklich gemacht wird aber man
darf das nicht unterschätzen wenn man
das einmal hört kann man vielleicht nur
sagen na ja aber das ist doch wirklich
der Wahnsinn dass man sowas äußert wenn
man das jeden Tag hört immer wieder über
Wochen und Monate dann setzt sich das
bei vielen Menschen auch fest und auch
das erleben wir oft wenn wir mit den
Menschen auf der Straße reden da wird
dann oft diese
skizzierte Propaganda in den
Staatsmedien die wird dann von den
Menschen in den Umfragen oft auch
wiederholt die Wut sitzt also tief
gerade bei ultra-nationalisten ist der
Angriffskrieg die sogenannte
spezialoperation bisher so ein
Misserfolg geworden ist wo die Russen
aber zynischerweise muss man sagen
erfolgreich sind in ihrer eigenen
perfiden Kriegslogik zumindest ist bei
der Zerstörung der ukrainischen
Infrastruktur die Russen haben in den
letzten Wochen 10.000 Marschflugkörper
und Raketen auf die Ukraine
niederprasseln lassen die komplette
Infrastruktur Zivil wir reden nicht von
militärisch Infrastruktur für die
Menschen Strom Warmwasser keine Heizung
Menschen sitzen in der Kälte und die
Gefahr dass sie erfrieren ist
unglaublich groß wie soll man auf dieser
Ebene mit jemand verhandeln wo wir beim
Stichwort werden verhandeln wer
verhandelt mit wem und kann man
überhaupt mit einem Aggressor verhandeln
der mutmaßlich für zahlreiche
Kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich ist sie
Christen töten lässt die mutmaßlich für
die Massaker in Butcher Verantwortlichen
Einheiten sogar mit Orden dekoriert ja
sagt der amerikanische Präsident Joe bye
aber nur unter der Bedingung das
Russland alle besetzten Gebiete vorher
ich bin bereit mit Mr Putin zu sprechen
wenn er sich entscheidet den Krieg
wirklich zu beenden aber das hat er
bisher nicht getan
trotzdem
verhandlungsmorgen Luft das Bein jetzt
signalisiert pass auf wenn du bereit
bist wirklich umzukehren wenn du ernst
machen willst dann bin ich auch bereit
dir diese Gelegenheit zu geben spreche
ich tatsächlich mit dir auf Augenhöhe
das ist sozusagen gutes Signal der
französische Präsident macron denkt
sogar schon an die Nachkriegsordnung und
sorgt sich um die Sicherheitsinteressen
einer der Hauptpunkte die Präsident
Putin nennt ist seine Angst dass die
NATO zu nahe heranrückt und die
Stationierung von Waffen die Russland
bedrohen könnten das wird in
Friedensverhandlungen eine Rolle spielen
eine klare Offerte Richtung Moskau quasi
von höchster europäischer Ebene auf den
Tisch gelegt Putin dürfen nicht
gedemütigt werden hatte macron übrigens
schon im Mai gefordert der neue Vorstoß
stieß bei den NATO-Partnern auf Kritik
macron habe quasi eines der Motive für
Putins Angriffskrieg abgenickt die
vermeintliche Bedrohung durch eine näher
rückende NATO manche sahen sogar eine
Täter Opfer Umkehr verhandeln ja oder
nein das Echo in Deutschland war geteilt
was der AFD und der Linkspartei Zuspruch
für macrons erfährte und der Wunsch das
Drängen baldige Verhandlungen zu führen
eine Verhandlungslösung muss her und nur
sie kann dafür sorgen dass der
schreckliche Krieg schnell endet deshalb
muss es so schnell wie möglich um ein
Waffenstillstand und auch im
Friedensgespräche gehen Instrumente der
Diplomatie andere auch in der Ampel sind
mehr als skeptisch solche Vorstöße
machen es unwahrscheinlich also zu
Verhandlungen kommt und nicht
wahrscheinlicher das fahrlässige Gerede
jetzt dass manche betreiben für dazu das
Putin den Eindruck gewinnt dass er
diesen Krieg noch gewinnen kann und
damit erst recht nicht bereit ist zu
Verhandlungen unserer großen Hoffnungen
und ich glaube das werden alle Menschen
am Jahreswechsel sagen hoffen dass der
Krieg im Sinne der Zivilbevölkerung in
der Ukraine so schnell wie möglich ein
Ende findet und wenn andere Instrumente
auch dazu beitragen können dürfen die
nicht einfach zur Seite gelegt werden
ich fürchte das Russland einsehen muss
dass es militärisch nicht zum Erfolg
kommen kann und deswegen müssen wir bis
dahin die Ukraine weiter militärische
unterstützen wenn das klar ist dann wird
Russland bereit sein zu verhandeln zu
irgendeinem Zeitpunkt möglichst früh
aber jetzt ist das noch nicht absehbar
die Gretchenfrage die spaltet wann ist
der richtige Zeitpunkt für Verhandlung
es gibt grob gesagt zweilager die auch
quer durch Opposition und Ampel gehen
übrigens die einen sagen wir brauchen
jetzt Verhandlungen damit das Sterben
aufhört und die Lage nicht weiter
eskaliert das andere Lager aber sagt
wenn wir jetzt verhandeln Stärken der
Putin verschaffen ihm Zeit das Sterben
und die Eskalation geht in Wirklichkeit
noch viel länger außerdem müsse alleine
die Ukraine entscheiden doch genau das
wird seit Monaten von Intellektuellen
Friedensaktivisten in Frage gestellt in
Appellen in offenen Briefen und Talkshow
Auftritten
stellungskriege ich kann es nicht fassen
wie im ersten Weltkrieg eine solche
Unmenschlichkeit also
genau deswegen ist aus meiner Sicht und
ich bin mehr denn jeder von überzeugt
die größte Solidarität
schnellstmögliche Verhandlung
herbeizuführen oder der jüngste Appell
vom Klaus möckling
Gesellschaftswissenschaftler an der Uni
Kassel scientists for future der sammelt
Unterschriften um die Bundesregierung
aufzufordern sich bei der UN für
Verhandlungen einzusetzen und zwar
schnell der Westen hat hier auch
Druckmöglichkeiten gegenüber der Ukraine
denn es kann ja nicht sein dass die
Ukraine uns alle in einen Weltkrieg
letztendlich dann hineinzieht ja ich sag
noch mal der Schuldige ist die Russische
Föderation
aber man muss auch der Ukraine deutlich
machen dass Sie nicht nur sich selbst im
Auge zu haben haben sondern wir haben
weltpolitische Probleme im Moment ne die
gesamte Weltwirtschaft hat riesen
Probleme
wir stehen am Rande eines Weltkrieges
und wir möchten auch hier in Deutschland
nicht hineingezogen werden aber es gibt
auch energischen Widerspruch wenn diese
Exponenten nun sagen ein Krieg müsse
durch Verhandlungen enden dann möchte
ich diese Leute ganz konkret Fragen
hätten sie 1944 mit Adolf Hitler
verhandelt das war nämlich das was die
Nazi Eliten sich bis zum Schluss
eingeredet haben der Westen müsste doch
irgendwann den Krieg zum Ende bringen
und dann mit uns verhandeln das muss er
keineswegs die meisten Kriege enden
nicht durch Verhandlungen sondern weil
eine Seite militärisch gewinnt Beispiel
zweiter Weltkrieg Beispiel Vietnamkrieg
ich möchte sie auch fragen wie hat denn
die sowjetische Invasionen Afghanistan
geändert etwa dadurch dass die Mutter
hier den Verhandlungen angefangen haben
mit der Sowjetunion nein man hat die
sowjetischen truppenhaus auf gar nicht
sein hinausgeworfen und genauso wird es
auch in der Ukraine kommen russland hat
gesagt es führt Verhandlungen wenn seine
eigenen Bedingungen erfüllt sind das
heißt z.B dass die Annektion der viel
Gebiete anerkannt wird das ist dann aber
keine Verhandlung das ist eine
Kapitulation diktatfrieden beide Seiten
waren tatsächlich mal weiter beim Thema
Verhandlung Istanbul im Frühling da ging
es um statusfragen um
Sicherheitsgarantien die Ukraine damals
in der Defensive war zu Zugeständnissen
bereit aber dann kam nicht nur immer
weitere ukrainische Erfolge es kamen
eben auch die schrecklichen Bilder aus
Botschaft aus irpin erschossene
hingerichtete Ukraine in den Straßen in
Massengräbern und die Bereitschaft über
Gebietsabtretungen zu verhandeln Schwanz
wird eigentlich gar nicht mehr
miteinander gesprochen doch durchaus
Behandlung gibt es immer wieder und
kleinere Verhandlungserfolge auch im
Schatten des großen Stillstands etwa
Verhandlungen über Gefangenen Austausch
der immer wieder gelingt oder das
Getreide Abkommen das einmal
ausgehandelt und der Erdogan einige
Unterbrechungen jetzt mal ausgenommen
ganz gut hielt und vielleicht auch auf
andere waren noch ausgeweitet werden
könnte aber die große Frage nach
Waffenruhe nach Frieden die wird eben
nicht verhandelt zumindest deutet
hoffentlich nichts daraufhin an
öffentlichen Vorschlägen aber mangelt es
nicht da kann man sich durchaus
vorstellen ich kann mir es vorstellen
dass unter Aegide der Vereinten Nationen
echte Referenten zum Beispiel auf der
Krim stattfinden das hat im Saarland
gegeben sie werden nicht alles
zurückbekommen also die Krim werden sie
aus meiner Sicht auf keinen Fall
zurückbekommen und das Ziel muss sein
den Donbass
zumindestens im Sinne einer
Teilautonomie
zu bekommen das heißt dombas muss
Ukrainisch bleiben von der
Staatsangehörigkeit aber er muss ein
ähnlichen Status bekommen wie
beispielsweise Südtirol in Italien
vielleicht fertige Sprüche naja jetzt
verhandelt doch endlich mal es kommt ja
nicht auf jeden Fall der Ukraine so
dringend an ich sage sehr klar und
deutlich
diese aus meiner Sicht dann doch naive
Haltung ist schon 2014 gescheitert
Außenministerin baerbock war ganz
aktuell auch vor einer Waffenruhe nach
russischen Konditionen das würde den
Schrecken der Menschen in der Ukraine
nicht beenden sagt sie im Gegenteil aber
das Problem ist es läuft ja nicht auf
ein Frieden hinaus sondern es läuft
darauf hinaus jetzt das ukrainische
vorrücken zu bremsen den Winter über
Putin die Zeit zu geben aufzurüsten
nachzurüsten danach wird er ja
unweigerlich natürlich die Ukraine
wieder angreifen und das wissen wir
historisch von weiter zurückliegenden
Beispielen was sind bringt gegen
jemanden der eine absolut imperiale
Absicht erklärt wir wissen es aber auch
von Putin selbst also die Sorge dass
Putin nur Zeit gewinnen will ein bloßen
Scheinfrieden die ist groß und dann die
Sorge dass er mit neuer vehements
angreift vielleicht sogar einen zweiten
Vorstoß auf vier Wagen könnte
[Musik]
im Moment also geben sich beide Seiten
hart der russische ergressor will nicht
ablassen von seinen eroberungsplänen und
die angegriffene Ukraine will weiter
standhalten und alle Gebiete ihr habt
2014 besetzt wurden also auch den
kompletten Don Bass und die Krim zurück
Präsidentin in Washington zweifellos die
spektakulärste Auslandsreise die ein
Staatsoberhaupt in diesem Jahr
unternommen hat
für mich als Präsident bedeutet ein
gerechter Frieden keine Kompromisse bei
Souveränität Freiheit und territorialer
Integrität meines Landes
und dafür hat der Präsident die
überwältigende Zustimmung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung in
Meinungsumfragen sprechen sich rund 85%
fürs weiterkämpfen aus und wir bleiben
an ihrer Seite solange wir es nötig ist
was sie tun und erreicht haben dass es
nicht nur bedeutsam für die Ukraine
sondern für die ganze Welt gemeinsam
werden wir die Flamme der Freiheit hell
leuchten lassen und das Licht wird
siegen über die Dunkelheit
ein enger Berater von Präsident Weiden
hat uns Journalisten hier gesagt man
wird auch nicht drängeln nicht anspornen
noch nicht einmal anpieksender silenski
nach einer Verhandlungslösung suchen
soll weil Vladimir Putin eben weiter auf
seinen Maximalforderungen behaart weil
er Städte in Schutt und Asche legt weil
er die kritische Infrastruktur angreift
und vor diesem Hintergrund ist die
Lieferung des Patrick Systems sehr
wichtig es hat eine Reichweite von 1000
Kilometern kann also eine weite Fläche
abdecken schützen vor innen
reinkommenden Raketen und auf der
anderen Seite wird Putin sein Volk auf
einen langen abnutzungskrieg ein die
spezialoperation in der Ukraine kann
durchaus ein längerer Prozess werden
ultra Nationalisten sitzen ihm im Nacken
und fordern einen Sieg also dass man
jetzt irgendwelchen Zugeständnissen
bereit wäre dass ich überhaupt nicht
im Gegenteil und nach außen hin gibt man
sich hier natürlich immer
verhandlungsbereit aber was könnten das
für Verhandlungen sein das wären
Verhandlungen und der russischen
Bedingungen auf die sich Kiew natürlich
nie einlassen würde und diese
Ausgangslage macht es extrem schwer weil
zu Verhandlungen zu kommen doch was sind
mögliche Szenarien die die Lage
irgendwie ändern dass man an den
Verhandlungstisch doch noch
zusammenkommt Szenario 1 die Ukraine
drängt die Angreifer militärisch aus
ihrem Land möglich aber dafür bräuchte
sie wohl noch deutlich mehr Waffen auch
Panzer und die der Westen im Moment
jedenfalls nicht bereit zu liefern
Szenario 2 es kommt zu einem
Regimewechsel in Moskau und und das ist
übrigens keinesfalls ausgemacht zu einer
neuen Regierung die bereit ist die
Truppen zurückzuziehen ernsthafter Druck
von der Straße auf Putin das sieht unser
Moskau Korrespondent hat er auch noch im
Interview gesagt jedenfalls nicht im
Moment fehlt einfach jeder Prominente
Kopf auch der prominente Anführer einer
Opposition der es schaffen könnte
vielleicht die Massen zu mobilisieren
also eine Art Aufstand der Anständigen
unwahrscheinlich Russland eskaliert
weiter das wer Szenario 3 zermürbt die
Zivilbevölkerung durch Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur womöglich sogar nuklear
Militärhistoriker neitzeln hält das für
wenig wahrscheinlich und die
zermürbungsstrategie für wenig
Erfolgsversprechen der rechnet für das
Jahr 2023 mit einem Pat ich glaube dass
wir dieses Interview in einem Jahr
genauso führen können und dass wir dann
genauso Fragen werden was wird das
nächste Jahr dann 24 bringen also ich
könnte mir schon vorstellen dass es auch
Verhandlungen gibt dass man auch die
eine Seite sagt ja wir sind bereit und
das ist vielleicht sogar Gespräche von
Unterhändlern gibt aber ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass wir dazu
substanziellen Ergebnisse kommen weil
die die also man muss es eigentlich
brutal sagen wahrscheinlich sind für
einen Frieden noch zu wenig Menschen
gestorben der grausame Zynismus des
Krieges losgetreten von Putin und der
Friede scheint stand jetzt in weiter
fern ist euch das zu pessimistisch was
meint ihr wie könnte ein Weg aus diesem
Krieg Aussehen ist ein Ende doch
absehbar oder war das erste Kriegsjahr
womöglich nur der Anfang einer
kriegsepoche die sich über viele Jahre
hinstrecken wird schreibt es in die
Kommentare diskutiert gerne mit und
abonniert diesen Kanal trotzdem düsteren
Prognose wir bleiben für euch dran an
diesem Thema und vielen mehr versprochen